yes I'm playing GTA 5 right now yes I'll
do a video on Breaking Bad when it wraps
but Dexter just rapped so we should talk
about that Dexter the continuation
of a review that I actually did when it
was in the first five seasons now and I
guess now we're wrapping it up so Dexter
was a show on Showtime that starred
Michael C Hall he was a serial killer
and all he ultimately killed serial
killer killed folks that deserved it and
I repeated the show when it was through
the first five seasons and I was like
this shows great because seasons 1
through 4 were so cool then the next
four season seasons 5 through 8 happened
and then the show wrapped and now I'm a
little underwhelmed seriously there's
something after the lip Gow season it's
like the show just declined it's gonna
have spoilers for people who haven't
watched Dexter so if you haven't watched
Dexter spoiler alert and what I mean by
that is if you've seen seasons 1 through
4 of Dexter you've seen what matters so
hey stick around
I don't mean to about Dexter in
this video I liked Dexter seasons 1
through 4 after season 4 had a lot of
missteps I'm going to touch on some
here at the end of season 4 they waste
Rita I thought the reason for that is
because Rita was humanizing Dexter so
much so like he can't actually have that
kind of human interaction so they waste
Rita next season what do they do they
get him a girlfriend and that doesn't
work out and what do they do a couple
seasons later they get him a girlfriend
it was kind of repetitive what we
learned was Dexter can not have
happiness with a chick next season
Dexter can not have happiness with a
chick now we learned that Dexter cannot
have happiness with a chick because it
causes death and now we can't have
happiness with a check I get it you
don't need to beat it over our head so
much I mean you look at season six it's
like colin hanks and edward james olmos
they're killing people together and it's
ultimately a Tyler Durden type of
scenario and then when Dexter finds that
out Colin Hanks is now evil Colin Hanks
but the way it would work is that he
would need to be nice good Colin Hanks
or he would mentally be edward james
olmos this teacher but when Dexter finds
out Colin Hanks is all evil and now he's
like yes I am evil Colin Hanks and I
need to do this for the teacher it's
like that wasn't how it was though you
were you were a good guy who had a
multiple personality disorder and you
good guy were not aware that you were
actually bad guy and now you're just
aware of it you're not the teachers mind
you're just you're bad now and you
always knew what was going on but you
didn't the kind of is just that's
that is bad writing the biggest wasted
opportunity
I felt was and I believe it was season
six it was when Dexter's finding
religion and his priest guy is like
don't kill this guy who killed him you
know forgive him and Dexter ends up just
choking the guy out in the water and
drowning him he turns up Harry Morgan is
going to heal he hallucinates with Harry
Harry's like his Jiminy Cricket
hallucination and it's his brother Brian
he's like hello little brother I'm like
sweet for the rest of the season is
gonna be bad Dexter's gonna be like when
angel lost his mind and became Angelus
in the show Buffy the Vampire Slayer and
they kept that going for this season and
it was awesome you can have a guy lose
his mind to become bad it actually makes
it kind of interesting and people Revere
that as possibly one of the more
interesting story arcs nope
one episode long after that Dexter finds
his wagon I guess that was a bad idea
that one tangent I did I guess I'm good
again the show Dexter got momentum back
when Deborah found out who he was that
was awesome I was like finally we're
doing something that puts someone close
to him in this really shitty situation
worse like I know what he is I'm a cop
and what to do and then look where does
like I think something's up with Dexter
and that was awesome and Debra wastes
LaGuerta and you're like that's awesome
in the beginning of the next season
Debra hates Dexter she's like I killed
the wrong person in that trailer and
she's all she's a wreck now and you're
like that's awesome consequences and
repercussions I get it in the second
half of the last season what is leading
to the series finale Hannah McKay comes
back and I now love story and Debra
patches her up with Dexter so all
of us really irrelevant the show did
what I thought it would do which is in
the second to last season someone is
investigating Dexter's like alright
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
and find out who he is and I always
thought in the last season everyone
would know who he is or like the Bay
Harbor butcher is actually this guy the
manhunt is on that would be the last
season I like the prospect in a show
like this that this guy's secret life is
coming to light everyone knows about it
now it's all exposed and he doesn't get
away with it because he just he's a
monster and he can't have happiness
which really the show tried to do but it
was like he's a monster he can't have
happiness with a chick come on really
with that at a point in season five
Joey Quinn is investigating Dexter he's
like something's up with Dexter he is so
convinced this guy's doing shady he
actually has photographic evidence that
he's probably dumping a body then he
forgets all about it then in the last
season he sees footage of Dexter
stabbing a guy with a pen at that point
though he's kind of like I don't care
that you killed him because I wanted
to kill one but it would have been cool
to just at least hear a flashback
flashback would have been fine because
they did a couple flashbacks in this
episode but it would have been cool to
see Joey Quinn have a flashback of those
moments where he he suspected Dexter and
at that point he's like oh he was
what I thought he was but I'm in a lot
of slide it's fine because he killed
this guy this guy who all right I'm
gonna get to the Bubba Fett death in a
bit getting back to the side
stories okay Vince Masuka apparently has
a really hot daughter so what what did
that have to do with anything in this
show had nothing to do with it was their
way of going we want Vince Masuka in the
show and we have no story for him he has
a daughter alright well I guess that's
just real that's relevant right alright
Bubba Fett death here
this is dumbest thing ever Debra Morgan
was such a cool character I always
thought Jennifer Carpenter out acted
everybody in every season she was
awesome and she gets shot in the stomach
by this guy who's also a stupid
irrelevant killer and she's like I feel
like she's laying in the hospital
and his killer guy's looking for her and
he goes to the hospital and Dexter's
there and Dexter's gonna confront him
and an angel puts a gun to this guy's
neck he's like on your knees
they take him away
oh you find out I guess during surgery
she had a blood clot it went to her
brain now she's a vegetable
I think Deb deserved a better way than
that if Deb's gonna die cool if you do
it right that was just some Dumbo it's
like the writers were like Deb needs to
die just kind of understood right right
okay Deb needs to die how I don't know
blood clots as good as any all right but
it's not not for that character that
character deserves something a little
more relevant if not relevant real you
can argue like you have a sometimes
that's how death is well that
I love Frank Lundy and I was fine with
the fact that that chick killed Frank
London because she actually tied in with
Trinity second to the last episode
Dexter season for John Lithgow looks at
Dexter's nametag he looks up he's like
hello Dexter Morgan you're like now he
knows who he is the world's falling
apart I never had that holy moment
in this season this is the series finale
I never felt like the world was ending
for Dexter and they do things like I
Dexter rides his boat into the storm
because he's like I cause death and pain
to everybody I'm just going to go into
the storm and die in his boat they find
the wreckage of his boat it's like cool
then
in the end he's still alive in the
middle of butt-fuck nowhere how why how
did he live through that then again how
did Batman live through the bomb answer
simple because I'm I guess actually
could be like because tonight's the
night we just never got a manhunt for
Dexter anyone who found out about Dexter
ended up dying the last season should
have been called Hannah McKay because
that was the manhunt that was happening
Hannah McKay is Dexter's chick pretty
much and she killed a couple people too
and that was the manhunt in this season
was Hannah McKay this Hannah McKay that
oh I gotta go and I'm looking for Hannah
McKay and Dexter's like I can't be seen
around Hannah McKay I a much bigger
serial killer cannot be seen around this
chick that they're actually looking for
the whole manhunt revolved around Hannah
McKay and it just stole the Thunder from
Dexter I don't like to compare
everything to Breaking Bad but if I
wasn't told flat out that Breaking Bad
was in its last season I would know just
by how the story is going Dexter just
felt like another season felt like it
could have been a season finale not a
series finale if I'm advocating Dexter
here it is watch seasons 1 through 4
know that when Rita gets wasted that's
where the world ends for him he's like
oh I guess I am just a killer and I
bring death because he's going to learn
that lesson three or four other times in
the show and it just gets repetitive in
bullshitty bullshitty the show would
have been a really solid five or six
season story like after Rita died you
could have had other people be like oh I
think something's wrong with Dexter and
in the end they find out and the sixth
and final season could have been the
manhunt for Dexter but in the end they
drew it out to where it really deluded
the entire show to be a lot of
irrelevance so the show Dexter and the
Dexter series finale what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you